hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
september 20th
2021 what's going on
[Music]
how's it going
how are you are you doing all right
that's [ __ ] fantastic
oh
billy [ __ ] old face
is off the goddamn road
i'll tell you it was an amazing run of
dates i want to thank everybody that
came out god damn it
um since i last
ran my yap
on this podcast
who you know you know it's one thing i
really like is fascinating to me now are
people that are doing documentaries on
themselves
you know what i mean this is a
documentary on me
oh yeah
uh who came up with the idea to do that
uh i did
i've always found myself such an
interesting subject
is that really
is it really a documentary
when you're the money you're the subject
and you're the money but like when
hillary clinton did one on herself let's
look this up here
i want to look this [ __ ] up this
fascinates me
people
who do documentaries
on themselves let's see what we get here
let's see what the list is here
that's just a bunch of nobodies here no
wonder they're doing a documentary they
need people to know who the [ __ ] they
are wait a minute
let's see if i type in
hillary i mean you know that like that
came but she's a politician
you know
michael jordan did it although i liked
his only because everybody was telling
his story all the [ __ ]
butthurt people in the sports press like
would you critical enough it's like you
guys tore him a new [ __ ] his whole
[ __ ] career you always had something
to talk about after you built them up
right
um
i guess if you're jordan it's okay if
you do it
you know
why is it okay
for jordan to do it and not hillary is
that because she's a woman no because
she stinks
that's the difference she's not the
greatest
politician of all time she does not have
six rings
okay
she was married to somebody who won two
rings
two terms
oh billy fresh hands there bill clinton
right she was married
oh billy grab ass there she was married
to him he had two terms right and then
she got you know she immediately became
a senator which was [ __ ] hilarious
you know
she kind of just got that job because of
like the last name being clinton right
you're part of a legacy
that's like when somebody goes to yale
and then they got a son who's a [ __ ]
dope but he also gets into yale
right
i'm the decider and he gets to go to
yale
right but like if if he had to do it on
his own [ __ ] merits you know what i
mean there is something to be said about
that
you know
it's like recently i was just signed
by coppertone you can't believe that
like i had i had no ins at that come now
that would never happen
do they even advertise that [ __ ] anymore
does anybody really want to get a tan
the old-fashioned way out in the sun
or did people do it the other way i
don't know i have no idea but i do find
it funny
you know when people want to
do a documentary on themselves i also
love a documentary
you know someone do a documentary on
themselves and they're in their 30s
oh they'll write their life story
in their 30s
i have an autobiography coming out you
[ __ ] 36
do you have a terminal disease like what
are you doing here you wrapping it up
you're wrapping it up
i'd like keith rich's keith richards
waited
he waited until he was well into his
[ __ ] 70s and just wrote a book called
life
and it was like i know it was like 600
[ __ ] pages and the one story that i
remember
the most
was that they in like the mid 60s they
went out and they bought
a chevy impala which is one of the best
looking cars
of all time and i love those mid-six
speaking of which i saw a 65
chevy impala station wagon
with krieger rims
and like the whole [ __ ] car was just
all patina just was all beat up looking
but it was it was just such like a i
haven't seen one of those
since i was a kid i mean those things
were going away
when i was a kid because i was a 65
by the time i was like four or five
years old that car would have been eight
years old eight years of like kids and
family trips and [ __ ] um and it was a
station wagon so most of them ended up
in the junk pile
so um
yeah i saw one of those the other day
[ __ ]
i didn't remember what the [ __ ] was i
taught i was talking about people
getting their own documentaries how the
[ __ ] did i end up talking about a 65
chevy impala station wagon oh the
rolling stones
i know when you guys hate when i do that
i lose my train of thought and you're
like what happened with the [ __ ]
story why should literally
i should have like a in a special email
for people you know when i started a
story that you actually gave a [ __ ]
about i didn't finish it
um
so the stones bought this impala
i always pictured it being white i don't
know why
and
they took off like the door panel and
they had their drugs behind it because
what cop would ever look there right
and uh i don't know they drove this
thing all around they got all high and
all [ __ ] up or whatever and somehow
they lost the car or they turned it in
or they sold it i don't know what
happened but he goes somewhere out there
if a car still exists
there's a 65 or 66 chevy impala with my
drugs
behind the [ __ ] uh the door panel
so
that was just one of his [ __ ] stories
you know and had he written an
autobiography well i guess you get that
one you get that story when we get all
the other [ __ ]
on the other side of heroin the other
other side of all of this stuff
um
so anyway i'm off the road i'm not doing
[ __ ] and uh
you know before i go back out again i'm
kind of back to my regular touring
schedule which is every other week but
um i want to thank everybody that came
out to red rocks that show could not
have gone
any better and i filmed it
i don't know what i'm going to do with
it but i have it
um and it's looking like it's a smart
move to have done that
you know
because the set went so well and who
knows you know we just keep walking
around you know
during all of this [ __ ] whether you
believe in the pandemic or not
what do you think there's a virus or it
is it whether you think it was made by
nature
or if it was made by the government
whatever it is it's the new reality that
we're in
and um
so who knows does
does the whole thing open up next year
does the whole thing shut down if it
does shut down
you know
i'll just [ __ ] put it out
as a specialist something you know maybe
i don't know but now i have the thing
actually
you know when i first did it i was just
going to kind of shoot it like just to
document it and then just the budget and
everything just ballooned into like a
real special i was like well [ __ ] it
i'll just have one
you know i can use it and not use it i
just got this [ __ ] thing and now it
went so well i was so
[ __ ] psyched and my vibe on stage was
great and i really think part of it was
because i watched all these norm
mcdonald videos
and i just thought he had such a uh
i don't know like he there was something
about his vibe that was zen
his comedy was and like
it wasn't about the result it was just
about what he thought was funny
and i thought as much as he said all
this crazy stuff i didn't find him to be
mean
really um
so i don't know i was thinking about
that
and i don't know
when there was 1.2 i don't know i'm not
gonna tell you all the stuff i was
thinking about but i was kind of
just in a really good place and we shot
this thing and i am
you know thrilled
that we got it and uh
i still cannot believe i got to do stand
up there
and how great it was
and everybody was just on board laughing
we were having a great time and in the
end when everybody left
a couple buddies of mine that i didn't
know were going to be there surprised me
and we all went out on stage
and uh smoked cigars
literally until the raccoons came out of
the woods and started [ __ ] walking
around on the seats trying to find
something to eat which i took a video of
and put it on my uh my instagram
um
but it was amazing it was one of those
deals where i got off stage and i was
just like that was you know
i got all of that one he got all of that
one so thank you for everybody for being
a part of that and then kansas city the
night before
played this amphitheater and it was just
like the coolest most well-behaved
crowd people were buzzed but they
weren't like wasted you know people are
having a good time but um
just to as i was joking with bartnik
going that might have been the best
wednesday and thursday i've ever had in
my life
so
yeah so in the end we were all just
sitting around
telling showbiz stories and
sports stories and all that was a great
mix of people and just sat on that
iconic stage smoking a cigar
and um
i i got a crazy story about that i
remember
about red rocks was a long long time ago
and i looked up the show too i forget
what year it was
but i looked it up because they had a
list of everybody and i saw footage of
stevie ray vaughan being there like a
fan shouting to him and him saying
what's up when he was sort of backstage
and i looked and stevie played there in
double trouble played first in 86
and then they came back in 87 88 and 89
and unfortunately
he died 90 so he went he went there
every single year after he played it and
i can't imagine
his music enjoying his music and that
that just seems like a perfect marriage
like riviera paradise
being played with the lights on those
rocks so anyway
i was
a nobody
and i was working uh the comedy works
i was post um
chappelle show tour
the late great charlie murphy and
donnell rawlings i think
i had just done
put out why do i do this and i was just
starting to get headlining work selling
a couple of shows and the others were a
little light doing morning radio and all
that that's where i was at so staying at
this hotel
and um finally you know it was a you
know nice
period in my life where i
had
gotten to the level
of uh working in a club
like you know the comedy works in denver
all right and actually finally staying
at like a nicer hotel
um
yeah you know i might have been almost
ready to do my second special because if
i was staying at that nice hotel
um i don't think what happened would
have happened so basically
i um
was at the hotel and i had the shows
that night
and um
[Music]
i went down to the hotel gym
oh billy balliptical right
and i go to get on the gym go i go to
you know go to the gym go to get on the
elliptical and i'm on the elliptical and
i'm listening to my music and everything
and as i'm on it
mca from the beastie boys came walking
in
and he looked at me i looked at him and
he knew i knew who he was and i didn't
say anything to him that's how i always
look at those people like that
it's like my gift to you for everything
that you've given me in your work is i'm
not going to bug you
i just want to say i wasn't going to do
that
so i did my thing i didn't say one word
to him
and uh i was like halfway done
with my workout and i just wrapped it up
you know i finished up and i left i was
like holy [ __ ] that was [ __ ]
mca
you know
like i can't the beastie boys must be in
town
and
uh and then like a day later or
something like that or the next morning
i went downstairs to have breakfast
and uh
ad rock
was downstairs
getting breakfast too and i ended up
talking to him because we both knew neil
brennan i think that was how that thing
came about
and he was going oh you're doing
stand-up i was like yeah he goes oh yeah
he goes you're doing your little
skittles
you're doing your little skittles over
at the comedy club he's like giving me
[ __ ] joking around i was laughing i was
like what are you guys playing and he
said we're playing red rocks
and i was just like dude that's got to
be sick have you ever had a quick
conversation with him he was beyond
[ __ ] cool
and um
i was like well i was just thinking i
didn't think i had never thought i'd
ever [ __ ] play that place because at
that time i'll be honest with you only
musicians could play that place
it was very few because i looked you
know they had everybody that ever played
there
um
bill cosby played there in 66 but it was
i think the capacity was a lot smaller
um in around 88 or 89 is when they put
the roof over the stage
but like the only other comic i
remembered seeing of everybody that i
read there was uh
was richard pryor played there in 78
when he was literally
at his height he played that place and
um
i think it's amazing like the internet
how the internet hurt music
it helped stand-ups
like i just feel like what we did was in
the way people consume our [ __ ] was
better for us
and it's just the weirdest thing ever
but anyway
i was thinking about all of that [ __ ]
before i went on stage and um
i still can't believe i got to play this
so anyway let me let me plow ahead so
now i'm off
the um
i'm off the road
and uh
i feel like i want to take a month off
but i can't and all i've been doing is
watching youtube videos of how
transmissions work
and people making homemade pasta
i don't know why
but i find it soothing
i don't watching what seeing how watch i
watched this video like a half hour
video
of this guy rebuilding a transmission
and i thought it was the coolest [ __ ]
thing i'd ever seen in my life and to
finally understand
you know i grew up i grew up driving
manual transmissions to finally
understand what was going on when you
were shifting
and um
and how like you know it was always
first second third fourth fifth and then
underneath was reverse and when
you know if you look at a transmission
there's like these rods
and as you're up and down you're moving
the gears to mesh with the other gears
but then when you go from second you
make that little s turn you jump onto a
different rod that then has third and
fourth and the other one has fifth and
then like reverse is a completely
different gear or or fifth i don't know
there's a lot to see
and just watching this guy and watching
him do it right
and then seeing these these things that
they put in because back in the day you
could really grind your gears but now
they the geniuses
came up with this thing that they put in
that helps you to like
just shift smoothly so you don't grind
the teeth of the gears
regardless if you're you're uh not going
the right speed when you were going to
shift
um because i've driven a few like um
four-wheelers and i don't understand how
these work the four-wheeler i drove you
had to shift with your foot but there
was no clutch
so you had to like listen to the engine
and make sure the rpms if they were high
enough if you'd shipped it to right time
it was like butter other times it was
just like fighting you or whatever so i
don't know i just got all fascinated
with that [ __ ]
so
tonight i'm gonna actually make myself a
little bit of pasta just to do it you
know despite you know
my you know my lovely wife is always
like why are you doing all we have pasta
in the box why
would you do that which is the hilarious
opposites
that me and my wife are aside from the
visual obvious
a beautiful black woman and a
translucent orange white man
um
yeah her [ __ ] is just like they make
pasta they put it in a box
you know what are we doing here and i'm
i'm i'm the [ __ ] guy like let's make
a sandwich we'll make bread from scratch
like i don't know i i
am fascinated with how [ __ ] works
um
so
i think i'm gonna be doing that tonight
and um
last night i put my lovely daughter to
bed
but my wife did
and i was like
jesus christ
i was like um
you know i was downstairs what was i
doing i was watching something i was
watching the untouchables
and i was just into the episode and i
can't watch the episodes when my
daughter's around because she's like
she's like dad i don't like when
the people get hurt and then they go to
sleep and i was just like yeah why am i
watching this in front i thought because
it was a 1950 60 show
it wasn't as bad but um just shows you
how [ __ ] up tv is now that i would
actually sit there and watch that with
the kid because i bet if you know i was
alive back then i'd be like all right
this isn't for kids say
um
so anyway my wife's like hey you're
gonna go upstairs and say goodnight to
your daughter i'm like you're right so i
go upstairs
to say goodnight to her and she was
already asleep
and when i was in new york i got her
halloween costume she's going to
spider-man
she's so freaking excited about i went
in there and she had
the spider-man
her uh costume she obviously didn't have
the spider-man head thing on
and uh
i thought that was so cool i was just
like i remember being that excited
about something when you were a kid like
you get a football for your birthday and
you'd sleep with it when you went to bed
you were so friggin excited was the
first thing you wanted to wake up and do
or play with and everything
so i went downstairs and i told my wife
i go uh
i go nia did you tell her that she could
uh
sleep in her
spiderman costume she goes no
i go where she is
and then
my wife laughed and was just like that's
why she had that look on her face like i
was saying goodnight to her and she was
smiling going all right can i and like
didn't really want to kiss just wanted
her to get out of there like she had
like that idea so this morning she came
downstairs
and i was making her some pancakes right
and uh i got this little uh
bruins tracksuit that i got my son
and i'm not gonna tell you something i'm
not gonna lie he's he's he's a
good-looking dude
all right my son and my beautiful kids
but this kid was crushing
this bruins
like i i've never looked that good in
bruins gear right
um
and i'm just laughing because i also
bought him these little pair of
timberlands when i was in new york you
know we haven't tried him on yet right
so he's just at that adorable age
anything you put him in is the cutest
thing ever
so i'm making the pancakes
so i say to my daughter i go hey
did you sleep in your spiderman costume
last night
she goes uh
no
i go yes you did i go i went up there to
say goodnight to you when you were
wearing it
and she kind of smiled and looked down
and i was like sweetheart i go don't
don't lie to me
you don't ever need to lie to me i i
don't care i think you know it's
nothing's a big deal just tell me okay
she goes okay i go so don't lie to me
anymore okay she was just like okay you
almost started crying i was just like no
it's fine
but i don't watch
just tell me what you did i'm not going
to flip out we'll work it out that's all
it's all i'm going complete
[ __ ]
opposite
of the the way i went
because it didn't it didn't work it
didn't take how i was raised turned me
into the angry lunatic that you all know
and love
but after time i think you guys listen
to me and you want to hear me flip out
because it makes you feel less [ __ ] up
or maybe it feels you're like all right
i'm not the only one who flips out over
[ __ ]
so
um
i flipped out this morning because there
was no vanilla extract to put into the
[ __ ]
pancakes because
what drives me nuts
and i was thinking about this so i
wouldn't flip out anymore is before i go
to bed i want to make sure all the
dishes are done and then every [ __ ]
thing is where it needs to be
because we've had these kitchen powwows
and i go the measuring cup goes here
okay
goes here goes there we're all in the
same yeah we're all in the same place
right
two days [ __ ] later where the [ __ ] is
it all right it's not at the sink it's
not in the dry wreck it's not
in the [ __ ] washing machine i have to
start my day with a [ __ ] treasure
hunt
drives me [ __ ] insane so this morning
trying to make these [ __ ] pancakes
and i'm trying to find the [ __ ]
vanilla extract
and uh it's nowhere to be found and it
used to be in the spike track
all right and then somehow it got moved
into the cupboard and then it got moved
down to the other cupboard where the
bacon [ __ ] was it just keeps [ __ ]
moving around like it's running from the
mob
like it's got warrants or something
so i look
it's not in the cupboard i look down the
bakery thing it's not there i look in
the spice rack it's not [ __ ] there
and i'm just like
but i was able to talk to myself it's
like bill
do you really want to ruin a sunday over
vanilla extract you're going to put
syrup on the pancakes who's going to
notice and i just was like you know what
[ __ ] it
just [ __ ] let it go let it go
you know
i mean why would you want things in the
place where everybody knows it is so
then you don't have to look
why would you want that
why would you want that when you can
just [ __ ] hunt all around the [ __ ]
kitchen
every two three days looking
looking for these [ __ ] things
the can opener can we just
agree
what [ __ ] drawer we're gonna put this
thing in
it's used all the [ __ ] time and i
swear to god
all right i'm done with this [ __ ]
because i'm actually really flip out all
right
how about those patriots
[Music]
the [ __ ] buffalo bills smoke the
dolphins
smoke the dolphins the 2-0 lone position
in the afc east the team to beat
it's not even a question are they going
to win the af
see east the question is how far into
the playoffs are they going to go
everybody's looking at the steelers like
oh wow they could do something and all
freckles put a little money on them
today you know to [ __ ] cover
and their 80s
came in and took that money right out of
my pocket
took it right out of the pocket derek
carr was playing [ __ ] great they got
john gruden
the raiders haven't been back since john
gruden brought him back
i mean i swear to god if this guy makes
the [ __ ] raiders a playoff contender
playoffs you know they should have a
street i would say a street in oakland
if there was anybody
left in oakland that wasn't pushed out
by all the people that got pushed out
of uh san francisco
which by the way
um
somebody used this expression and i got
to see this episode of south park
it was like
south of
south of south park what the [ __ ] was it
they did south park did a whole episode
on gentrification
i see south park
gentrification
episode
and you know how they name stuff like
weho
and all of that [ __ ] they did like a
thing like i can't believe that that was
just sitting there and nobody else had
the brains that's why they're geniuses
they're like [ __ ] 19 20 21 seasons in
nice
oh season 19 episode 3.
um south park so they came up with one
of those stupid [ __ ]
wee ho soho noho
[ __ ] hoe thing and it was uh
it was i think it was s-e-s-o-p-a
some
see so
si sopa or something like that i didn't
see the episode but it was just making
fun of all of that [ __ ] it's epis season
19 episode three i'm gonna watch that
tonight um
i gotta see that man oh then wait a
minute that was 2015. i'm way more
i just thought that just came out i'm an
[ __ ]
well there you go now you know whose
comedy you should be listening to i'm
six years behind south and an idea south
park had that i didn't even have
um hats off to them i gotta check that
out um
so
anyway um
yeah the steeler i'm gonna be the
typical gambler the steal is [ __ ] me
the saints [ __ ] me
and the rams [ __ ] me i'm such an idiot
i took all favorites this week i never
do that usually i take one favorite and
three dogs and i went all favorites and
i'm like i'm gonna go [ __ ] oh and
four instead i went
one and three what a dope
um
but anyway let me see uh
who gives a [ __ ] right
i'm having a good time i played red
rocks i'm making my own pasta tonight
i'm gonna make my own pasta tonight i'm
gonna do it right in front of my wife
and she can't have any because she
didn't want any right
it's a stupid move bill i know it is
um
i'm trying to think what kind i'm gonna
make
those [ __ ] pasta makers they just sit
there and they go this is how you do it
there's no way to film it
you can never see it
because whatever they do they have to do
it fast they just roll it off
and yeah that's that's how it is you
just fold the triangles in and you twist
it like that how did you just do that
slow it down
all right uh butcher box everybody
butcher box be prepared
for whatever life throws your way
with high quality meat delivered right
to your door easy ladies we're talking
food here whenever you need a great
tasting meal you can trust butcher box
is in your corner each box has 9 to 11
pounds of meat of your choosing options
like 100 grass-fed and finished beef
free-range organic chicken humanely
raised pork wild caught lobster tails
and wild caught alaskan salmon they've
teamed up they're on a crime spree
nobody knows what they're gonna do
sugar-free bacon luckily today's sponsor
butcher box is offering our listeners
ground beef
for life
john wayne's dream ground brief for life
uh no i probably ate steaks for a
limited time butcher box is giving new
members two pounds of free ground pre
beef in every order for the life of your
membership imagine
never having to stop for ground beef
again this deal is a no-brainer once
signed up you choose your box and
delivery frequency
they offer five boxes four curated box
options as well as the popular custom
box so you get exactly what you and your
family love
butcher box ships your order frozen at
peak freshness and packed in
uh at 100 in a 100 recyclable box and
shipping is always free
you enjoy great tasting
high quality meat delivered right to
your door this is your chance to never
have to shop for ground beef again
that's right butcher box is giving new
members free ground brief for life and
on top of that for all monday morning
podcast listeners butcher boxes offering
ten dollars off of your first box sign
up at butcherbox.com
and get two pounds of ground beef free
in every order for light for the life of
your membership log on to butcherbox.com
to claim the deal oh look who it is
everybody would you look who it is it's
old zip
you know people there are some things in
life that i like to pick out myself
so i know
i've got the one that's best for me
like a cigar
i like to pick that out myself i don't
want someone else to pick it for me
there is that what i'm supposed to do in
this read like cuts of steak mattresses
bottles of wine
yeah why would you let anybody else
choose that well bottle of wine i would
cause i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] is there
anything worse than when they bring that
wine over to you and they pour it in
they're standing over you
they know you don't know what you're
doing you swivel around you stick your
nose in it
you swish it around they know you're
gonna say yes that's a gangster move to
send it back
to send it the [ __ ] back how insecure
are you though if you send that thing
back and you still don't know [ __ ] about
wine
just being like i gotta send like
whenever you five i gotta send them back
uh anyway what if you could do the same
thing for hiring choose your ideal
candidate before they even apply
what am i spying on people
that's where zip recruiter invites to
invite to apply comes in it gives you as
the hiring manager the power to pick
your favorites from the top candidates
and right now you can try it for free
that's it
[Applause]
dot com
how does invite to imply work well when
you post a job on zip
they spend the most they send you the
most qualified people for your job
then you can easily review the
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply for your job
it's like you're behind a two-way mirror
lauren webb
the senior vice president president of
talent acquisitions for medulla health
raves
about zip recruiters invite to apply she
says i love that feature because we have
a much higher follow through rate if i
invite candidates
it's easy for me
and it's easy for them in fact according
to zip recruiter internal data jobs
where employers use zip recruiters
invite to apply get on average two and a
half times more candidates which helps
make for a faster hiring process out of
all this [ __ ] that i advertise on this
podcast this is the biggest no-brainer
ever
you know what i mean you want to [ __ ]
hang a piece of paper on a telephone
pole
or do you want to have access to the
entire talent pool uh see for yourself
just go to exclusive web address
this exclusive web address
siprecruited.com
spell out bar b-u-r-r to try zip
recruiter for free that's
ziprecruiter.com
the smartest way to hire
all right jesus christ i got two more
here people candid
you know there's a specialist for just
about everything right
when your car breaks down you go to a
mechanic when there's a problem with the
shower you call a plumber
when you get covered you talk to your
friend
um so when
see when you want to get your uneven
crooked teeth fixed you see an
orthodontist they're the specialists
and that's what sets candid the
invisible comfortable and removable
aligners above the rest
while poorly reviewed or insanely priced
clear aligner companies use general
dentists
candid only works with orthodontist the
specialist this is what they do
all right
if you walk up to an orthodontist and
you say man i got a cavity he goes get
out of my face
i don't do that low rent [ __ ]
huh
goddamn dennis glorified hygienist get
the [ __ ] out of here i'm all
orthodontist
i move mountains in your mouth
when candidate when candid sorry the
same orthodontist who created your plan
well with candid the same orthodontist
who created your plan
is with you from start to finish
so you never have to wonder how you're
doing
orthodontists have their own office
dennis and hygienist they share a space
okay orthodontist is uh he's beyond
business class your treatment is
prescribed and closely monitored
remotely by a licensed orthodontist
who's an expert in tooth movement you
can book an appointment at candid at a
candid studio near you or do everything
from the comfort and convenience of your
own home the average candid treatment is
just six months so you'll start seeing
results way before then and it costs
thousands less than traditional braces
um
yeah you have straight teeth man you
gotta love straight teeth you get
straight teeth people think you're a
straight shooter
hey i got another guy looking at this
cordova in a half hour
that's what they all say but
god damn look at those teeth
uh and with your free aligner treatment
you'll get candids treatment whitening
for free straight teeth white teeth
come on they're gonna be falling it in
the bed all right candid can help uh you
get the straighter brighter smile you've
always wanted right now you can save 75
on your candid static kit when you get
started from home or you can book an
appointment at candice at a candid
studio near you today go to
candidco.com and use the code bird
that's candid co charlie oscar.com use
code bur take advantage of this limited
time offer to save 75
dollars on your starter kit candidco.com
code burr
lastly but not least lead the headliner
here
stamps.com you know you've heard me talk
about stamps.com
christ they've been sponsoring this show
for over nine years
and if you haven't tried it
you know what are you waiting for
since 1998 stamps.com has been an
indispensable tool for nearly one
million businesses and let me put that
into historical perspective there were a
lot of dot-com comp companies in the end
of the 90s that literally tanked
wall street
pets.com all of this [ __ ] horse [ __ ]
they were around back then
they were legit it's like they played
baseball during the steroid era
and they always piss clean
all right stamps.com brings the services
of the u.s postal service and ups
shipping right to your computer whether
you're an office sending invoices a side
hustle etsy shop or a full-blown
warehouse almost said whorehouse
warehouse shipping out orders stamps.com
will make your life easier all you need
is a computer that's all you need is a
computer and a standard printer no
special supplies or equipment within
minutes you're up and running
printing official postage for any letter
any package anywhere you want to send
and you'll get exclusive discounts on
postage and shipping from usps and ups
once your mail is ready just schedule a
pickup or drop it off no traffic no
lines cut the confusion
out of shipping
such a weird pause cut the confusion out
of shipping it's cut the confusion out
of shipping with stamps.com's new rate
advisor tool you can compare shipping
rates and timeless to e and timelines to
easily find the best option save time
and money with stamps.com there's no
risk and with my promo code bar
all capitals you get a special offer
that includes a four-week trial plus
free postage and a digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts just
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage and type in
burr that's stamps.com promo code bur
stamps.com never
go to the post office again
well there you go all right
damn with that what else did i want to
talk about was there any other story oh
i've been getting a kick out of like i
get a lot of [ __ ] emails you know
people calling me hollywood and that
type of stuff and people's idea i swear
to god i'm not saying i'm not hollywood
all right
i'm not saying that i'm not laying here
right now thinking
that if i sent out
a tweet
and told you
about the new hoodie that i just bought
that in my mind i don't feel that i
would entirely shift
the entire hoodie economy
i have that level of an ego no just
people [ __ ] on [ __ ] hollywood who
don't even live out here and don't know
anything about it and then how they act
like everybody where they live
you know what i mean is just the salt of
the earth guy
you know joe's six-pack he puts his
pants on one at a time yeah is that what
he does what else does he do
what else is he [ __ ] doing you know
like you don't have [ __ ] sex
offenders in your goddamn state i am so
[ __ ] sick
of this [ __ ]
you know
i have been sick of it it's just funny
to me
that with like all of this vaccine get
vacs don't get vaxxed how half the
country is like get facts the other half
isn't
is like
you know saying i don't want to get
vaxxed
all right
which i understand both because you know
white people have come up with
vaccinations white you know i don't know
whatever we gave syphilis to black
people i get it you don't want to take
it i get it the [ __ ] head of one of
those [ __ ]
facts things the ceo didn't take the
vaccine i get it i understand the
trepidation but half the country's like
yeah i would do it other half now you
shouldn't [ __ ] do it but then somehow
it becomes hollywood's the only one
saying to do it it's so [ __ ] dumb
it's so [ __ ] dumb it's just i don't
know
i have a great time out here i'm not
gonna lie to you there's a lot of
scumbags out here absolutely but there's
a lot of scumbags contractors
right
it's a lot of scumbag teddy bar a lot of
scumbag priests
a lot of scumbag car salesmen scumbag
everything real estate agents
p you pick a vocation and you tell me
there's dirty cops
there's firemen that steal [ __ ] during
the fire
right
i just you know what it is is every time
there's a [ __ ] natural disaster out
here
meaning the united states
these [ __ ] look to hollywood and then
we put on our tap dancing shoes and we
we raised money
to go find your cow that [ __ ] floated
away
or your [ __ ] that burned down
or swirled away in the wizard of oz
[ __ ] tornado we're always there for
you and the second we turn on we catch
on fire you guys ah let it burn those
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and then you call us phonies go [ __ ]
yourselves
other
49 states
in most of california
that's me i'm sticking up for hollywood
all right
next week i'm sticking up for
scientology
yeah maybe they did some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
but is there any worse than all the
other religions
as far away i see it they're playing
catch-up
that's what i said my buddy oh
scientology that's a fake dude call me
when they start [ __ ] kids
all right reservation dogs everybody oh
i did an episode of that oh by the way
man
by the way the [ __ ] uh the buzz on
that show if you're not watching that
show man you're not in the in crowd
and i have like a little little little
little little tiny part in that show but
like uh i was i've been hearing nothing
but rave reviews they got renewed for a
second season i think before the first
season even came out they are crushing
it over there
um
they just
it's a really exciting show and once
again somehow somehow
i this this has been my career
i never create the amazing thing
unless i co-create it with mike price
and it's called f is for family
uh my my the genius of what the [ __ ] i
do is i let other smarter people create
cool [ __ ] and then somehow i parrot
troop in it for an episode or a sketch
or you know a little uh you know
recurrent thing
and then i get some of that their genius
stink on me and people start looking at
me you know
like my tuxedos fit me a little better
you know
all right reservation dogs everybody hey
oh billy
chocodee
i hope i said that right
they told me a hundred times how to say
that and then they were like well even
if you [ __ ] it up it's still funny
because it fits your character
um
thanks for the reservation dog dogs roll
been a fan since way before that though
first time writing a dumb ass message to
probably andrew
uh yeah he's the one who reads these or
whoever checks uh
these things um just finishing watching
your episode and a nice little cry old
puss boy here he says i always knew you
were one in the legend you have no idea
how much this show means to me
uh my best friend took the daniel root
in 2010 oh no and a few days after that
my brother got into a drinking and
driving accident and didn't make it
jesus christ and since then i've been
pretty lost i found the mm podcast
around 2015 and has helped me an insane
amount i even quit drinking the day you
did get the [ __ ] out of here i only
lasted 100 days though i've done that
yeah but dude you did 100 days so you
got it in you
um
i just wanted to finally send you a
thank you note and i don't want to get
i don't want you to get too big of a
head so i'll just cut it off here thanks
and go [ __ ] yourself from a little res
kid in saskatchewan canada p.s i really
hope you're in more than one episode uh
well if i'm smart i won't go back again
because i think i pulled it off
go back [ __ ] the bet on the next episode
it was just a fluke
um yeah that's a funny thing yeah i i
can't believe i uh you know
i get a lot of
you know
scripts and stuff sent my way and this
was the one that really stood out just
the writing in it
and the ride that they were taking
people on um
you know
i'm so glad i took that role i think
it's amazing to be a part of a show
as great as that and um
and then for all actors coming up i'm
telling you just always
[ __ ] taking the money unless you
actually have to always take the best
thing
okay
if you're always taking the money i feel
like you're stacking bricks
but if you're always taking the best
thing it's like you're building a wall
you know what i mean do a little comedy
do a little drama do a little sci-fi go
back to the comedy and then they start
getting this idea that you can actually
act okay if you keep playing the same
[ __ ] person churning butter that's
that's all they see
um so i want to thank
uh this person and everybody else who
watched and i really want to thank the
show and all the writers and everybody
for
you know who's getting who you just all
i have to do is say what they wrote
stand on a piece of tape and then they
edit it and they make me look great so
and i can continue to not have a real
job and never really work in life
um which was the goal of mine
i had real jobs i had real jobs that i
did not enjoy that were real work i did
a little bit of landscaping i was a i
was a [ __ ] grunt on a construction
site i landed i lasted like eight days
on that i was just like i i don't have
it
i i i could i'm smart enough that i
could hang around here and eventually
become competent but i do not have a
gift for this
so i walked oh billy [ __ ] see you
later
um
oh by the way when i was looking at
those things watching people rebuild
transmissions i found this amazing
[ __ ] video
of a 1980
ford f-250 that had they found it was
sat in a heated garage
or warehouse
for 40 years and only had 76 miles on it
it was [ __ ]
gorgeous
gorgeous had a couple little scratches
on it for people walking by it i didn't
really understand the story as to why it
stayed that way
um but other than the tires just being
flat from sitting there you know they
had to get new tires on it
um
it was gorgeous man absolutely gorgeous
i don't know what it is about old pickup
trucks i can trucks and [ __ ] like that i
can look at those things
forever i never grew out of like having
tonka trucks and being a little kid and
seeing like i thought like the guy the
milkman the garbage man anybody drove a
truck i thought was like the was
they were like paul bunyan
it's [ __ ] amazing
um anyway
i wonder if my son's gonna like tonka
trucks
he's such a sweet kid always comes up
and he gives you a hug and then if he's
not doing that he just is destroying
stuff so i feel like i have like a nice
well-balanced kid here
um super sonic air
travel oh i think i know what you're
going to say because i saw an
advertisement for it at newark airport
hey billy goat of comedy oh thank you
um been catching up on the podcast since
i discovered it a couple years ago but
this is my first time writing in i heard
the recent episode on 9 13 21 where you
briefly talked about supersonic flight
you mentioned that it was discontinued
after the crash and hasn't been used
again at a commercial level
i thought he goes since you are a fan of
aviation i thought you might be
interested to know that it's actually
coming back soon
i don't know if you consider this soon
united airlines i saw this ad actually
took a picture of it
and sent it to vinnie brandt
who's eventually going to be on this
podcast
vinnie brand the club owner of uh the
stress factory
um
we shared a common dream to fly the
concord to france or to london or
whatever and i took a picture of that
and sent it to him when i saw it united
airlines is going to be reintroducing
supersonic flight in 2029
so that's eight years away
i will be
61 years old holy [ __ ]
wow man
53 to 61 that's a quick oh and it's a
quick ride
uh who gives a [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] enjoying
myself i i don't care about uh
age anymore as far as like that's a
great thing about becoming if you if you
get older and you just embrace being
older
and just sort of let yourself become an
old man i'm not saying like you know
give up
um
and you understand that you have no
control of aging
even though you always know that when
you truly
give into that
that you can't stop time
you know
so but no one can stop you from enjoying
it so as long as you're enjoying it
you know there's kind of like
i don't know like i picture laying on my
deathbed as being peaceful
and smiling and thinking about all the
fun that i had that's what i'm hoping um
that is the goal
uh anyway huge fan of everything you do
thank you so much for all of it and
congrats on your self-development you're
an inspiration to other knuckleheads i
am a knucklehead
i am a recovering meathead that's
exactly what i am uh like myself who
wants to live their best life basic
white girl voice i really want all you
other meatheads out there to live your
best life
you know when white girls say living
their best life it means they're 100
focusing on themselves
so they can live the best life possible
regardless of who has to suffer
[Applause]
anyway he says but seriously you and the
podcast have been there for me through
some rough times i appreciate you thanks
again and go [ __ ] yourself you know that
really means a lot to me that uh
there's other people that are [ __ ] up
out there and that you get something out
of this um
i i figure it's just the fact that you
hear me trying
um all right let's read about supersonic
flight here oh my god united adding
supersonic speeds with new agreement to
buy aircraft from boom
supersonic
well what do they want for a supersonic
jet maybe me and all the podcast
listeners we can all go in
we can all go in and buy a supersonic
jet
imagine the scheduling it's booked for
the next [ __ ] 18 months chicago and
denver june 3rd 2029 2021 sorry united
airs today oh that's where it announced
i guess that's their hubs
oh would you look at that [ __ ] it
looks like a dart
oh my god is that a sexy [ __ ] plane
united will purchase 15 of boom's
overture airlines
what a great name once overture meets
united's demanding
safety operating and sustainability
requirements
with an option for an additional 35
aircrafts
the companies will work together on
meeting those requirements before
delivery once operational overture is
expected to be the first large
commercial aircraft to be net zero
carbon
from day one
uh can you buy stock in this company
optimized to run on a hundred percent
sustainable aviation fuel saf is slated
to roll out in 2025 fly in 2026 and
expected to carry passengers by 2029
united and boom will also work together
to accelerate
production of greater supplies of saf
sustainable aviation fuel
isn't that exciting where where would
this fly
you know it's funny this is i'm going to
keep doing stand up until you can fly
supersonic anywhere anywhere
just go to [ __ ] des moines iowa
right
supersonic is like north of what speed
what is what is that's breaking the
speed of sound which we all know is 700
what how many ma speed of sound super
sonic
uh the speed of sound is 768 miles an
hour
so just remember six seven eight except
you flip seven and six seven six eight
seven hundred sixty eight miles an hour
which means you could get you know once
you get up to that speed you could fly
across the country i would think in
about three hours as the crow flies
right
the mach number is the ratio of the
speed of the aircraft to this to speed
of sound
okay let's learn about mach let's come
on people let's do this mach speed
explained
all right
by definition mach is number is a ratio
of the speed of a body
parenthesis aircraft to the speed of
sound in the undisturbed medium through
which the body is traveling
undisturbed medium through what's the
body how is it undisturbed
you know there's the friction of the air
it's flying through all right
is it
it is said that the aircraft is flying
mach 1 if the speed is equal to the
speed of sound
okay so then is mach 2 twice the speed
of sound
well now they're saying
speed of sound is 717 miles an hour all
right why do i try to be smart all right
31 year old virgin
honeymoon advice
hey bill i'm a lady listener and enjoy
your advice section of your podcast the
most um
i have an idea for you you should reboot
the 40 year old virgin and make it a
[ __ ] woman
that's what you got to do uh my my
fiance and i are both from california
just in case you think we are from the
bible belt region
um i didn't
i didn't there's a lot of virgins that
are that you know either through
religious beliefs or maybe you got
touched when you were a kid you don't
like being touched and you're a late
bloomer
you know there's people that are asexual
there's just you know there's a whole
bunch of [ __ ] that could have happened i
don't judge anybody when it comes to
that stuff
all right uh we met two years ago and
finally getting married by the end of
this year
we both are fairly conservative hence
we've both never done it before what is
your advice for two 31 year old virgins
who will finally do it for the first
time on their honeymoon
oh my god this is two rookie
quarterbacks facing off in week one have
a nice day with your family
um
oh
number one don't put any pressure on
yourselves this is both your first
rodeos
i would say have fun and uh
you don't really have to do it the first
night
if it's too much if you're freaking out
or whatever you can start i would just
both of you
you know
just talk about before you do it this is
a monumental thing for you if you waited
this long
and i would just yeah just really be
like
[ __ ]
you know the whole thing in a
relationship from ground zero up because
you have to be communicating
so um
i don't have any advice you're gonna
figure it out
it's nature you're gonna figure it out
just have fun enjoy yourself if you're
not enjoying yourself just say you know
maybe maybe we do it the next time or
whatever just you know just
i mean this is above my peg right here
people like i i don't i don't know what
okay it's a beautiful thing
you guys are gonna enjoy yourselves
and uh
i think about you know a week into it
you know
you're probably both gonna have a
difficulty holding down a job because
you're gonna be one in a bank
so congratulations to both you have fun
all right
girlfriend tried to break up with me
hey bill from over the hill
oh man i watch this [ __ ] you know my
wife likes watching the murder shows
before she goes to bed just like that
great snl sketch she either watches that
or she watches dumb reality
so we had on this i swear to god a game
show about reality shows
it was the stupidest [ __ ] thing
people sit there and somebody goes like
well say like one of the reality show
stars says something to the other cast
member members and they bleep out the
word so you can't see what it is
and then you have to try and guess they
tell you what the word was and then you
say true or false i swear to god i was
like i can't watch this [ __ ]
so she puts on this [ __ ]
murder show
and it's just of this beautiful i'll
fast forward to all of this [ __ ] this
beautiful girl gets killed by some
[ __ ] creep she meets online
and it turns out this creep is one of
these kids who can't get [ __ ] laid
they used to be called nerds now they've
they're like halliburton they gave
themselves a new [ __ ] name
all right
and
i don't you know i don't know what their
deal is they end up getting mad at these
women because they can't get laid you
know when i was a kid it was called a
slump everybody went through a slump so
if you're out there right now you did
the last thing you want to do is start
hating women because they're just going
to be turning them off and now you just
you you're trying too hard
all right you got to go watch fast times
at richmond high you don't care if she
comes stays laser praised yeah you got
the attitude right you got a [ __ ]
self a little vibe you know
these [ __ ] lunatics this kid goes out
and he kills this poor girl and then
like
he took video of him doing it in
pictures and these [ __ ] [ __ ]
online were sending it to
uh her parents and what [ __ ] killed
me
is there's no protection for the parents
and then
the people that were writing mean [ __ ]
when they showed their mean tweets
they're blurring out their twitter
handles like so you're protecting the
[ __ ] and not the parents it was one
of the most heartbreaking things i've
ever seen
and that's the last thing we watch and
then we go to bed it's like what what
the f
i just don't know
i just looked at my life i was like well
that was uplifting
yeah i really like humanity now
big fan of people uh girlfriend tried to
break up with me
uh
hey bill from over the hill i was dating
this girl everything was going well
for the first few months until the red
flag started to show up it seemed
everywhere we went in her hometown
she had a story how she and her ex had
sex in that particular place
she told you that
oh
jesus dude i mean
you got to walk when that happens all
right could you could you be saying that
to her
hey my last girlfriend uh whose boobs
were just a little bigger than yours i
bet her over that [ __ ] rock over
there
what what what did i say
um
all right he goes on to say
um i don't know about anyone else but
the last thing you want to hear on a
date with your girlfriend at the local
pizza pizza joint is how she used to
bang it out with old dick and harry on
the same counter
as they rolled out the dough
yeah when i explained this bother me she
said how i was jealous and needed to get
over myself yeah this is a toxic [ __ ]
person
that is hurting you and now is blaming
the victim dude
i this is like a [ __ ] no-brainer just
i don't even need to read the rest of
this i will
uh that this is this is one of the
easiest decisions a few months went by
and one day she told me some lady
on social media was
massaging her
you know messaging is what you wanted to
write
asking if we were together
but would not to close disclose who it
was
i told her i had no
clue who would do such a thing later she
claimed it was an old co-worker of mine
but it seemed out of character for that
particular person so i didn't follow up
the next few months i would start to
receive strange messages on this is this
your psycho girlfriend
doing this to you the next month few
months pretending to be somebody else
the next few months i would start to
receive strange
messages on social media and through
text messages from girls claiming they
met me on dating apps and wanted to see
how i was doing i didn't respond to any
of these
yeah this is your psycho girl she's got
a burner phone
jesus chris is some [ __ ]
glenn close fatal attraction [ __ ] then
one day my girlfriend once again claimed
someone had messaged her on social media
this time the person claimed i was
unfaithful which started a huge fight
between us where she had asked me if i
had been seeing anyone while we were
dating i told her i had not but when we
initially met i was talking to someone
else but had stopped once we started
seeing each other more exclusively she
claimed this was cheating and she had
lied
about someone messaging her because she
wanted to prove i'm a no good scumbag
and we broke up well there you go dude
and listen let her think that this is
how you break up with the psycho
okay you're a no good scumbag just like
you know
act like you're fighting her
but let her win
and then she leaves change your number
change the locks
maybe change your zip code
just get the [ __ ] out of it anyways a
few days after i decided to contact my
former co-worker to ask if my then
girlfriend had ever contacted her she
said nobody had ever messaged her she
didn't even know i was dating by this
point i found out my ex
was already in a relationship with her
ex
oh that's great
okay so she just used that as a way to
get it break wow how [ __ ] elaborate
this is why they got to teach people
kids how to break up with people
if i was ever a junior high or a high
school teacher i would say hey listen
you guys are in the beginning of dating
it's great
but one of the things that i wish they
told me is how to break up with somebody
and just say listen we need to talk
you sit down and talk and you say listen
i'm not happy in this
okay
i'm just not happy i i like you but i
don't like you enough
to keep going
and you just get that information out
there and then they cry and they flip
out and blah blah blah but you don't
back down from how you feel
and then that's it i'm not happy and you
just get the [ __ ] out of it you get out
of it instead of having to create phony
accounts anyway by this point i found
out my ex was already in a relationship
with her ex
she would always brag about banging in
all these locations yeah
yeah so she probably cheated on you and
this [ __ ] guy probably cheated on her
and uh he'll cheat on her again but
guess what you're out of it you're
you've been extracted
from this situation
like an undercover cop
who you know they're getting too close
and they have to pull you off the
[ __ ] case you're out
you're out
anyway
he goes i think it's safe to say she
made up contacting my family my former
co-worker absolutely i also believe she
had been the one contacting me from the
strange number in social media accounts
absolutely what do you think bill was
she behind all of this in an effort to
end the relationship yes and she's
batshit crazy
okay and she's gonna go back to that
[ __ ] other dude that the only reason
why he's banging her is because she's
batshit crazy and is [ __ ] wild in the
rack okay but neither you
or him want to have kids until sh with
with anything like that until that thing
figures out what the [ __ ] it is
all right that's a wild animal
okay you ever see when they get an
animal in a [ __ ] trap
right and they fix it
and then they try to set it free
and it [ __ ] jumps out of the cage and
then jumps into the cab and starts
scratching up the driver or the [ __ ]
doctor that helped that's what the [ __ ]
you had let that thing run into the
forest
um
that is it and i'll tell you wherever
you met that woman do not meet your next
girlfriend there you're gonna need to
start fishing in a different pond
um
wow man
[ __ ] psycho
you dodged a bullet you dodged a bullet
anybody that ends up with that
if she stays where she is and doesn't
grow as a person or figure out what the
[ __ ] is wrong with her dude i mean
dude you will you will hold in like
nuclear waste in your [ __ ] hand and
you know
this other guy's carrying it now good
for him have fun buddy have fun i am out
see you later seacrest out all right
girlfriend dresses like a [ __ ]
all right dear bill
um yeah you can't you're not allowed
really like people like
stop close shaming her
and it's like well you do
i mean i would love to interview like a
prostitute and just be like you know
with all the mainstream women dressing
like prostitutes now is it hard to like
you know figure out what you're gonna
wear every night all right dear bill
first time writer long time listener
i've been listening to a girl for three
years
and she's getting antsy about us taking
the next step she's awesome a great
conversationalist and gorgeous so what's
the issue you might ask well bill she
dresses like a [ __ ] i'll go [ __ ]
yourself dude you've been with her for
three years
you've been with her for three [ __ ]
years did she just start dressing like a
[ __ ]
because if this has always been an issue
you've been wasting her time but if
you're young i understand because you
know how to break up with people and you
start thinking well will i ever get one
as pretty as this again
maybe i can make myself love her anyways
well bill she dresses like a [ __ ] now i
know this might sound judgmental but i
don't
i don't mean it too dude
having a gorgeous woman woman that
dresses like a [ __ ] is a situation for
a guy when you go out in public
all right because she's going to attract
male attention and somebody one of those
[ __ ] guys is gonna cross a [ __ ]
line and then all of a sudden you gotta
step up like you got [ __ ] steven
seagal you know skills
right
is that too old uh joe rogan skills all
right there you go updated it
okay not comparing joe's [ __ ] art to
his i don't i'm not in that world all
right
both of them can kick my ass okay there
we go all right
um so what's the issue you might ask uh
okay all right she dressed like her
however i want you to imagine the worst
case scenario on this one when i first
met her i thought this was a one-time
thing but every day she wears skirts
that end at the top of her ass
see-through tops that show her nipples
or short shorts with no panties that
reveal her vagina
she even went to a costume party and
only body paint and a thong
buddy she's been doing this the whole
time
she's been doing this the whole time so
evidently you've been having fun
but now you're like i don't want
the mother of my kids walking down the
street with their clam hanging up is
that what the issue is
anyway i don't believe men should tell
women what to wear why women tell guys
what to wear all the [ __ ] time
you're going to wear that you need to
update your wardrobe i mean what is this
my favorite shirt get rid of it
but she dresses like this in front of my
friends and male relatives and i feel as
if i've gotten to the point where it's
emasculating for me
i 100 understand that my friends stare
at her like they want to [ __ ] her
despite me standing right there
the way she dresses attracts the worst
attention absolutely and i've almost
been in countless fights because of it
yes guys have tried grabbing her even
while i'm staying there and i'm a big
guy she claims that men are the problem
and that it's just nudity furthermore
she claims that she can dress how she
wants because a man doesn't own her
um
yeah all of that is true
she can dress how she wants a man does
an owner this is all about how you feel
about it and if this is a deal breaker
for you i would get the [ __ ] out of this
um this isn't new either she told me
that her mother has been screaming at
her
her entire life to put on clothes trying
to understand her i guess that she might
be a nudist that prefers spaces where
you don't have to wear clothes well yeah
if she's in there i would think that
that's a safer space
um
because everybody's naked you're all on
the same playing field
are there less perverts at a nudist
place because the guy's balls are right
there he doesn't even have underwear and
pants to block the kick
i mean your nuts are just hanging out i
would think that you'd be on your best
behavior
i offered to take her there but she
replied that she only like to be naked
in places where she's not supposed to be
all right so she gets off on it all
right this is like her thing so you
either have to be okay with this
or you got to what judging by your
answer i've told her that if she were a
man
that
love to show his genitals she would be
labeled a pervert
yeah
yeah well you know
but also you know you got to look at how
we're set up
uh
anatomically is that the worst right
word
how our [ __ ] is our shit's hanging we
put our thing in somebody
so that's why you know
they're a receiver we are the
i'm the decider the doer
i'm so involved in my head here i think
it comes down to this she he says she
has mentioned several times that she
needs to be the center of attention
which sounds like a bit of narcissism
right yeah dude you can't marry this
this is a [ __ ] nightmare
anyway is it too much to add this is the
type of person that's gonna have kids
and is gonna be competing with the
attention
of if you have a good girl she's gonna
be first of all she'll be dressing her
girl like a [ __ ] girl like a [ __ ]
all right and then when the your
daughter gets into her teen years she's
then going to start competing with her
and there's going to be a [ __ ]
nightmare
anyway i'm just this is it i don't have
any [ __ ] degree in anything here
other than talking [ __ ] but this is what
i'm guessing anyway is it too much to
ask that i want to be the only one who
sees her naked vagina no it isn't should
i stay with her and deal with the
constant negative attention from friends
and on lookers or cut bait and
potentially lose an awesome person
otherwise dude i never heard you say in
any of this that you love her
i think she's [ __ ] smoking hot
and the exact [ __ ] reason you walked
up to her
is the exact thing that's driving you
away which you know
whatever you're going to say about that
it's just like
dude that's not
it sounds to me like you don't want your
mother the mother of your kids doing
that
uh yeah
you know she has the right to do that
absolutely and she you know what she
needs to do she needs to go out and find
a man that's strong enough
to have to fight half the [ __ ] bar
every time you go up to go pick up a
[ __ ] pizza
um yeah dude i gotta tell you something
man
my wife is as cool as it [ __ ] comes
all right and marriage is still a lot of
work especially when you have kids if
you're already having these [ __ ]
issues
if you're already having these issues
and you're not even [ __ ] married yet
dude it's not gonna get any easier
okay and i also think somebody like this
is not gonna age well
in that they're not going to accept
aging
all right and then what you're going to
have is somebody with a botox clam
hanging out of the bottom of their
[ __ ] mom jeans that they decided to
cut off when you're going over there for
a [ __ ] play date dude you don't need
this [ __ ]
okay um so i would break up with her and
just say yeah listen
um
yeah the way you dress uh i can't handle
it anymore
and uh
but i don't want to tell you how to
dress i think you should be free to
dress the way you want to dress but um i
think you need to go out and find a man
that is comfortable with that and then
if she tries to be like well i don't
want to lose you i'll only dress like
half a [ __ ] no don't do that because
now she's being
what she isn't
okay and now you're doing to her what
most women do to men which is they try
to change you into what the [ __ ] they
want rather than finding what they want
which is what you need to do
okay
this look you're doing something right
if she's gorgeous and you landed it you
can land another gorgeous woman that
doesn't walk around with the [ __ ]
tits and ass hanging out all right
and you're not into it so you answered
your own question so i would [ __ ]
walk
i would walk and then you know
i don't want to predict this but you
might lose another one of your friends
once she becomes single and you know
something dude she can [ __ ] have her
all right
he can have her i've been there too
i've been there too and you know what
you do when you handle that you just be
really cool
you be really [ __ ] cool
with your buddy
and it'll drive her nuts
[Music]
all right that's it go [ __ ] yourselves i
will talk to you
i'll check in on you on thursday uh
oh here's my prediction even though i
didn't take him uh i like green bay
tonight monday night football and i'm
going to tell you why
they got their asses whipped last week
by the saints the saints showed up and
got their asses kicked against
carolina they had a letdown game
and i think the packers bounce back
because i was watching the nfl
and bill cower
phil sims boomer siason jim brown
uh the burleson guy they all [ __ ]
read him the riot act that he looked
like he was on the sideline and he
didn't even give a [ __ ] anymore so i
think they lit a candle under his ass
and he's gonna come out firing it and uh
i take the packers
which i didn't but by the way also i
went one and three this week so
why would you listen to me all right go
[ __ ] yourselves i'll talk to you on
thursday